hey guys we're the contemporary fashion
brand cult naked we're from ukraine
our mission is to empower women and make
comfortable sexy clothes
[Music]
we're currently published in forbes
herpes bazaar vogue etc
we were worn by celebrities like kendall
and kylie jenner ariana grande and
armani
[Music]
so basically we're kind of
[Music]
bob sugar says we're the new celebrity
favorite
[Music]
we started as a really small brand of
three people from our little tiny office
and grew into
16 people in the main office plus
outsourced plus outsourcing pr
and outreach in america
so this happened
over the laps of three years in march
2018 we addressed caroline greeland that
pretty much kicked off our celebrity way
of marketing
um and this is where we are right now so
this is uh these are some of our vogue
publications not all of them obviously
but we're super proud of it and we
decided also to place it on the uh
on the wall kind of um this is monty
he's helping us breathe really well
and um
we're gonna move on to the samples this
is our studio basically studio slash
showroom kind of thing that we're doing
we're shooting all the content here
that's why the samples are hanging here
our business is based in ukraine because
because of many reasons first of all
the people
there's a really huge creative cluster
here there's a lot of talented young
people that you can work with we have
great uh we have great modern
infrastructure it's very if you heard
about ukraine you probably heard about
iit about fashion industry about all of
this
stuff and
and it makes a really good
kick here so um
i think young people are doing really
great job in ukraine i'm gonna show you
guys our first very first item this is a
squirt um this is inspired by a tennis
and
you know the uniform and it has shorts
underneath and we thought it's gonna be
our product for like one season but um
it turned to be
an all-time favorite of our customers so
that's why we're prolonging it and it's
gonna last so we're gonna always produce
it so basically this is our hero product
i think if
you're having some kind of stigma around
uh how it how it is here you should just
come and visit
and try and you know and try and dive
into our creative cluster because it's
very inspiring
[Music]
i'm very proud of ukrainian quality of
production when it comes to fashion
there's a lot of
people who know what they're doing and a
lot of people who want to learn
a lot of big brands come to ukraine to
outsource
ukraine is in the center of europe so
it's really easy to operate and navigate
here and that's what makes it a great
country for business
so this is the
in famous trousers
they go
their thing why these trousers not other
trousers why celebrities love these
products because people keep asking me
this all the time um that's because
they're super long and they're really
fitted on the waist they have a really
nice fit on the butt and you know stuff
um that's why
they make you look
insanely well like anybody i haven't
seen a person that looks bad and in any
of our closing that's our thing
basically we make women look good and
feel really good about themselves um
yeah and this is how we go it makes me
really proud that our business model is
not so harmful for the environment and
is really ethical because we work in
ukraine and we have our office
everything all together we know which
conditions our
sewers are working it we we know which
conditions everything is produced in
which is very important to have an uh
to be an ethical brand um also our plan
is to get more sustainable to get more
sustainable uh textile and be
more of a power brand of 2100
you know
this is a small part of what we do and
here all my precious girls are uh doing
all new stuff for gold naked and we're
gonna try out the new top that they're
constructing right now i think this is
gonna be a
total hit i'm super in love with this
item
and also we're gonna
i just like literally cut the stop and i
want to want to do it with the recycled
plastic um
kind of textile and we're gonna try it
out today too
so
just get in
um i want to be new age i want to be i
want to create something different i
don't want to go
start standard classic retail that is
very harmful for the environment so
that's where we're going at the moment
and that's what we're trying to inspire
others to do
so exciting
this one is a little complicated
because there's a
a lot of
um
it's not a ribbon what do you say
my ribbon elastic there's a yeah there's
a lot of elastic bands on it
and they have to
go some kind of way
but i'm very very excited for this item
very excited
at this moment we're sending out
thousands of orders um to our consumers
in united states and britain in
australia and europe sometimes
china also right now we're
not the biggest brand yet but i'm really
proud of where we are at right now
[Music]
every day we work to inspire
other young people to create a new
train every day i want to do something
better
i don't want people to think locally i
want to thank people to think globally
my personal mission to
create more workspaces
and to create more inspiring workspaces
in ukraine
i want everybody to say like oh you know
ukraine is the
fashion part of europe
[Music]
i'm done
i'm done
and i'm wearing gold naked